well let me ask you about Trump on that
front about the election 2020 election
and
maybe the better question is about
January 6th do you think January 6th was
a big deal
I do
how big of a deal
compared to what
uh Civil War
I think it was less of a big deal than
the Civil War okay no I mean so you well
it's a very interesting thing though
right because we have not only the the
event that's that's clever actually it's
not only the event but it's what led up
to it and what has happened since and
did it change what is considered on the
table
that citizens can should or might do if
they disagree with the results of an
election so I think that there are
further reaching consequences than just
was the six hour period on January 6th a
bigger smaller deal than the Civil War
and there's so much wrapped up into it
um many conspiracy theories flowed from
January 6th as well uh 60 Minutes
recently featured a guy named Ray Epps
who was targeted by some on the right
um claiming that he was an instigator or
an agent of the FBI or something along
those lines uh there were people
claiming that no real TR was like a no
true Scotsman sort of thing like Trump
supporters wouldn't Riot so by
definition it must have been antifa uh
police let him in or police were you
know all these different things I think
it was a big deal in a lot of ways
because it completely made us have to go
back to the top to say okay what are the
parameters of valid discussion and
activism in the United States but what
aspect of the January 6 was bad for you
well
I mean like if you're thinking from a
big philosophical political perspective
so presumably the number of people hurt
and the number of people who died
is not the only metric to consider here
absolutely I think the sum total of what
it means about how the United States
operates is what's most concerning and
I'll kind of just like flesh it out a
little bit so
summer of 2020. Trump's already saying
they're going to cheat
now the polling
is close but it shows that Biden's in a
good position people aren't happy with
Trump any reasonable person would look
and say it's going to be close but Biden
certainly wouldn't be a crazy thing if
Biden won Trump's already saying they're
going to cheat with mail-in ballots or
they're going to cheat with early voting
or they're going to cheat with machines
or we should do only in person or
whatever else the case may be we have
the election
we knew in certain States how the vote
count was going to go some states stop
counting at 10 pm some states count all
of the mail and stuff up front some
don't everything was completely
predictable
uh at 2 A.M Trump comes out and says I
won
okay but where are you getting that sir
as he claims people always refer to him
where are you getting that and with that
statement immediately we see that there
is a large portion of this country that
either is unable or unwilling to say
wait a second
the polling all said this was a real
possibility
the counting schedules are all being
adhered to
all but Trump won that doesn't make any
sense that doesn't happen it builds
people are donating Millions to Trump
for supposed audits which nobody can
Define and lawsuits which go nowhere and
it builds and builds and builds and we
have a total separation from a factual
reality there's no reason to think by
December 1st right give three weeks to
look through some of the stuff by
December 1st there's no reasonable case
to be made that Trump actually won
but it doesn't end there it goes into
maybe we can just like send different
electors even though Biden won Arizona
Let's just like send I don't remember
how many electors it is in Arizona Let's
just like send Republican electors to
say we vote for Trump but that's that's
not democracy that's not the way the
system works let's make sure we're ready
ready for what exactly and then it
builds to maybe Mike Pence can just like
prevent Biden from being present or
maybe we can just interfere in this
other way and then it gets to let's
break into the capital
it's the height of saying we no longer
comport ourselves attached to what is a
verifiable factual reality
and when we no longer do that we're also
willing to commit crimes property crimes
violent crimes okay different degrees in
order to try to have something other
than democracy it wouldn't be democracy
if any of those things had happened yeah
I I think it's not the height of it I
think
there's still a case to be made that
that did not leave the realm of protest
versus
a violation of the principles of
democracy so to me the height
of what could happen on January 6th is
uh if Donald Trump was much better
executive uh he could take control of
the military if it had succeeded
no not even succeeded the attempt would
have been more
um
empowered
I understand so like
the way not to bring up Hitler every
other word which is something your
subreddit also told me not to do okay
it's kind of an important figure it's
interesting to study that moment in
history because it reveals so much about
human nature and that all of us are
capable of Good and Evil but thank you
dear subredditor or redditor for your
contribution to the conversation I will
keep bringing up Hitler in the Third
Reich and I'll keep bringing up Stalin
there's so much to learn from that
anyway the
enough
um an effective practice authoritarian
could roll the tanks out into the city
streets
to uh establish order
and in so doing pause the process of
democracy
as opposed to a few protesters breaking
in to a questionably uh protected
building I agree that what you're saying
would be worse I don't want to use it to
minimize what the protesters were intent
on doing they failed fortunately oh but
to you the intention was there well the
intention was Trump should remain
president that's the intention and to
what length they would have been willing
to go if by the evening early evening
they you know were sort of like forced
out I don't know I agree with you that
Trump trying to use the military uh
would absolutely be worse you know
there's these reports that he tried to
seize voting machines which is kind of
funny because it's like once you get the
machine at Mar-A-Lago what do you do
with it exactly I don't know there's a
like a comedic element to Trump sitting
around with voting machines but he did
float trying to do some other things I
don't believe there's reporting that he
actually tried to use the military